hey guys Matt here from code Tech and
tutorials I know it's been a while I
want to make a quick video and show you
guys some of my favorite C plus plus
channels as uh I might not be making
videos quite as frequently so maybe I
just show you some of the ones that I
like to watch
um basically the only criteria to be on
this list was if these people come out
with new videos I tend to watch them as
soon as I can so that's that's the
criteria it doesn't necessarily mean
they're the best channels to learn or
whatever there's no particular order I'm
probably going to skip over a lot of
them that are that you would think would
be on the list of C plus plus channels
just because well some of them
um
I guess there's just too long to watch
every video they come out with or
something like that or uh you know
honorable mentions might be in here but
uh you know what really kind of made me
decide to watch this or make this video
is basically I just did a Google search
for like C plus plus channels and like
quite literally none of the channels
that I thought were good were on the
list it was just all like stuff that was
like what why would that be on the list
so
for example C plus plus YouTuber and we
get Caleb hurry this guy I'm pretty sure
hasn't made videos in like four years so
why is that on here I don't know code
Beauty uh this is more of a click bait
Channel I don't know if the info is that
good or not but basically it's just like
hot chicks talking about code I don't
think the quality is all that high so I
don't know why this would be on here
either uh never heard of this but when I
looked at it it's mostly python
tutorials so I don't know what that has
to do with C plus plus really other than
python is made with C plus plus or C not
sure what this is free code Camp is just
kind of random long tutorials about
various things not very specific date C
plus plus again the New Boston doesn't
make videos anymore although I did used
to watch those when I was starting out a
long time ago but yeah he hasn't made
videos in many many years as far as I
know programming knowledge really
doesn't have anything to do with C plus
plus it's just mostly python tutorials
once again simply learn I have no idea
so I was it's like what why why would if
you search for C plus plus YouTubers you
get a bunch of channels that aren't
really relevant anymore
and obviously I'm not on the list so why
what's going on there
just kidding just kidding obviously um
most of these channels have upwards of
nearly a million subscribers so that's
like probably part of this search
criteria obviously I don't have a
million subscribers so I'm not going to
be on the list no matter how good my
channel is and really all the good ones
that I actually watch none of them are
listed here
so I'm going to give you uh my list of
actual good channels that I watch
and I'm not I'm going to try to avoid
saying anything negative I'm going to
try to only say the positive things
about these channels that I know so try
to make this kind of a more uplifting
positive video all right let's get into
it
um got a little list here
and I'm just gonna go in no particular
order
well one that's pretty obvious
um is Javid X9 this should obviously be
on that Google search list why it isn't
blows my mind but you almost can't find
this guy so and it's one of the best C
plus plus tutorial makers in game
development makers I'm a little biased
towards game development so a lot of
these kind of talk about a little bit
about game development too but uh Java
X9 he's uh super good at this stuff
teaches you all kinds of things about C
plus plus how to do things lots of
tutorials lots of uh
math Integrations really good stuff yeah
anytime this guy comes out with a new
video I watch it as soon as I can and
absorb as much as I can because
some good stuff some really really good
videos from Javid so he's definitely on
the list definitely check him out
subscribe to his videos if you want more
content sort of like mine
um obviously somewhat different but
um same in the regard that uh
teaches C plus plus stuff his is
probably a little more computer sciencey
I think he's probably a little
a little bit more knowledgeable on the
math side than I am
as far as I know I'm not sure if that's
100 accurate but that's the impression I
get when I watch his stuff and that's
one of the reasons I like is because
there's a lot to learn and if you watch
my channel you're probably really going
to enjoy his too all right let's go to
the next one no I probably couldn't do
this video without mentioning the Cherno
I watched most of his videos although
um I have kind of fallen off watching
his videos a bit for no particular
reason other than a lot a lot of the
stuff I just kind of already know but
it's really great for learning C plus
and game development and he kind of does
some reaction videos and stuff as well
some but huge game engine Series this
one's really good if you can manage to
get through most of this you will learn
a ton and just just a lot of kind of uh
they're just good content if you're
trying to get better as a programmer and
better as a game developer or really
anything in this series
so uh I think that the best thing his
channel does is he just kind of explains
things really thoroughly and well so
when he's doing a video on something you
tend to know that you're going to get
content that's going to explain it
pretty well
and uh yeah most of you've probably
heard of the show no I think when I look
at like my channels
um
something page one of the pages says
like I share most viewerships with the
show now so I'm guessing that a lot of
you already know about this one but if
you're not subscribed don't watch the
videos definitely check him out
a lot of good content
another really good one that is a little
obscure is CPP nuts this guy makes a lot
of tutorials about just how to do really
specific
things in C plus plus and they tend to
be pretty good and pretty accurate as
far as I can tell so if you're trying to
just get better at C plus plus and
handling data and learning how to use
the libraries and stuff this is this is
going to be a good channel to watch and
take a lot away from
so highly recommend this channel as well
and he still seems to be making videos
so that's awesome
definitely check him out subscribe to
his channel and uh learn what you can
there
some great content
now I will say
um a little more serious on this channel
he doesn't oh man I didn't want to say
anything anything I guess this is a
negative just just a caveat like the
first two channels I mentioned uh Javin
and Cherno they they tend to have a
little bit of entertainment Factor on
them copnuts is more
more specific to exactly what's going on
kind of a little bit less entertainment
Factor but that's that's not necessarily
a bad thing it's just it's probably
better for learning actually so that
might even be a good thing however
YouTube doesn't care about that they
just want something else I don't know
what they want I actually I have no idea
what YouTube wants anymore I don't know
how to make videos that do well on
YouTube I just get lucky sometimes
another big one that you've probably
already heard of but in case you haven't
C plus plus weekly with Jason Turner
making C plus plus fun and accessible is
what his little about thing says and
that's uh probably probably as good as
good as the description gets however
there's a lot of like fine compiler
details that he gets into a lot of uh
comparing
we'll say comparing different ways of
doing things and seeing which one is
faster and stuff like that and it's
usually breaking it down to the compiler
level so I think this channel is really
good to watch if you want to understand
more about how C plus plus works on a
lower level and how it
compiles down to
machine code a bit I guess uh usually
looks more at the assembly than machine
code
so I think this is a really good one if
you're if you're new to C plus plus or
if you're even pretty Advanced I think
it kind of goes well from new to
Advanced so I think that's one of the
really good things about his videos and
I tend to watch pretty much everything
that comes out on his channel too a lot
of good takeaways I've definitely
learned a ton here and I think a lot of
you guys could probably benefit from
checking out a lot of his content too so
check him out
another Channel I watch quite a bit is
chili tomato noodle this channel is a
bit more vulgar than all the others just
a fair warning for some of you that
might watch with kids around or
something this one's probably going to
be more of one for headphones
when a lot of game development a lot of
C plus plus and recently he's been
getting into uh hacking ROMs or changing
ROMs which I thought was really
interesting and really cool and
something I've always kind of wanted to
do too so it was really neat to see him
start to dive into that definitely check
him out a lot of really good C plus plus
stuff on Chili tomato Noodle and quite
entertaining too in my opinion so show
him support
and uh definitely
definitely take away what you can if
you're trying to learn from this channel
as well
another really good one is bisquit I may
have mentioned this a bit before in past
videos
bisquit is incredibly Advanced and
obviously incredibly smart I I often
cannot keep up with his videos because
he's just doing stuff that's I have to
re-watch and re-watch and and dig into
to even understand like 10 second clips
of his videos so kind of on a whole
another level uh
yeah definitely good if you want to get
nearly
uh Advanced as as possible that's a
weird way of wording that but yeah I
think watching a channel like this
you're going to get some really good
computer science and C plus plus content
and apparently he's talking about
frequencies recently I haven't watched
some of those yet but some really good
stuff on his channel
um
yeah definitely highly recommend
watching I just I just love seeing him
hack things together it is very
entertaining and a great learning
experience at the same time so
definitely check him out if you don't
know about that channel
and if you haven't heard of handmade
hero or Molly rocket I don't know if the
name changed or what uh not real sure
but
he has a huge huge swath of stuff about
well I guess it's mainly C but it tends
to be a lot of C plus plus as well but
if you're really trying to learn C and
want to do it from a video form uh this
handmade hero
series seems to be really good I haven't
watched all of it but I am trying to
keep up and trying to catch up with a
lot of it there's also uh I guess you
don't say here but he does have an intro
to see so if you're very new check out
his intro to see video or playlist I
think the way to watch this channel is
to go to his channel check out playlists
and just check out
uh whatever you want you know whatever
you're interested in really good content
seems to be pretty accurate generally
knows what he's talking about so would
highly recommend if you're looking for
more C plus plus in computer science
content there
uh I'm going to mention a couple more
they're not necessarily A C plus plus
related as the uh the others have been
but I figured I'd just get them in here
because I don't think they're as well
known Jonathan Blow a bit of a
controversial figure in some ways but
obviously very intelligent and works on
a lot of cool projects like his own
compiler in games and he does some
streaming and stuff too but he often
produces some pretty good content
especially related to more of the
industry of of this kind of stuff
because uh I think he kind of trying to
think how to explain it
I don't know he just kind of Dives in
and talks with the community a lot and I
think that's really good he answers a
lot of questions and I think he does so
very honestly and there's definitely a
lot to learn here it might be hard to
get like uh you know beginner tutorials
here but once you start getting more
advanced or if you're just trying to
sort of learn the culture of how to do
things correctly without
caring too much about the current meta
but rather you know just like what is
actually the best way without
you know as I don't know about you but I
find that the public or general most
popular pin opinion seems to be wrong
for a lot of the stuff I'm doing and I
think he kind of coincides with that so
I really like like his takes on things
just because it's another angle that you
don't often hear but usually quite good
so definitely check him out if you
haven't
and the last one I'm going to mention
probably one you also uh know about or
maybe you don't I don't know thin Matrix
now he doesn't really do C plus plus
stuff it's more Java but it translates
really well the concepts are almost
exactly the same and he does a lot of
Dev logs recently but there are some old
past Java game tutorials and I actually
went through a lot of these early ones
along from a long time ago and did them
in C plus plus instead of java because
the code is almost exactly the same the
concepts are almost exactly the same so
it actually
felt pretty good and worked pretty well
although it doesn't necessarily fit the
title of this video since he mostly does
Java but it's just very easy to transfer
from java to C plus plus once you get to
get beyond the beginner level so I think
this is another really good channel to
check out it also gives you an idea of
stuff you could do from scratch because
he doesn't use any game interest or
anything he writes all his own stuff
including his renderer and his game
engine and it's all his functions so
that's really cool it's just really cool
to see what you can potentially uh you
know do
with uh just from Total scratch and all
on your own and it's just really cool to
see someone using all open source stuff
and making games and documenting it
quite well
and I just love to see all these types
of channels supported so that's all I
got for now that's everything on my list
um I'm sure there's a bunch more you can
leave comments down below if you think
there are some great ones that I missed
and uh just you know consider supporting
all these channels and if you want to
see more from me consider supporting I
kind of need video ideas right now well
one of the reasons I haven't made a lot
of videos is I I feel like I don't have
any great ideas for videos right now
I've been trying to come up with some
and occasionally I'll come up with one
here and there
but uh for the most part I've been
pretty busy working on other things or
on more private projects that I can't
really share on YouTube or I can't
really stream so that's just been a lot
of my life recently but if you want to
leave some comments about other good
channels or what kind of content you'd
like to see from me that you think I
could do well that'd be great if you're
on patreon or if you're a member of this
channel your comments are going to hold
a lot more weight and I'll try to
respond to everything so uh yeah I guess
that's it I appreciate you guys thanks
for watching I hope you found this video
useful hope you find some of these other
channels useful and I'll see you guys on
the next one take care peace out